good morning joy you don't know me but
I've been watching you for many months
now don't be surprised that you winded
up here you are ignored all of rulings
yet you were killed with your business
dealings considers a chance and joy to
cleanse yourself of all your sins that
is not going to be easy though
you see I in mind one of the best in the
world
and today I have you in my process you
can't run you can't hide your no weak
alignment if you manage to reach me at
the top of the seal consider yourself
absolved
you are not allowed to interrogate it
because if you do I will kill you thank
God okay hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to let's play
haunted now this is another game to come
out of this okay hi
it's alright there's another game to
come out of the seven-day first-person
shooter game jam where a lot of games
have come out and apparently I'm being
hunted and he's trying to shoot me in
the face and I gotta get up there so
that's what I'm gonna do and I'm gonna
try to avoid being shot rather not look
here we go oh god he got me he got me
good
he got me right in my goober huh he shot
me in my goober where is he I don't even
know where I'm going gonna get done I'm
getting a shot my first know where he is
I think I don't I'm just gonna poke my
AHA I think I saw something I think I
see you you bastard you're at the wait
what oh well this isn't gonna go well
hasn't yeah it's like a heart attack
every time I poke my head out huh my
crotch oh my god
gosh stay cross don't get oh this is
hard
this isn't as easy as I thought it's
like nerve-racking
okay never played a game that sincerely
mimicked the idea of being shot at
it's loud - it feels like something's
going through my brain no no don't not
my brain not my beautiful brain okay I'm
just gonna crawl real slow on my belly I
did not I can't hit me Kenya I'm just
out of range
uh oh you suck ah it's got big lot but
I'm just gonna crawl on my belly till I
get to the top of the hill died 20
minutes ah ah you can't at me ha ha ha
ha
all right sorry this is gonna be a long
hour-long playthrough you guys but it's
gonna be worth it nah see I tried to run
he got me ha ha ha didn't Lily okay hit
me I don't think you can hit me right
here right now I jump Oh Oh who's
dancing in front of your gun which
dancing - dude ah that's not fair this
isn't fair how do I win how do I win can
I go up here no cannot can I have a gun
yeah I know he said not to retaliate but
at this point I think it might be for
the best
Oh God try to uh he's good he's good
that guy how do I get up there on the
world ah
ah all right I'm doing worse uh was
before ah
as soon as I poked my head out he's
gonna blow it off
just crawl crawl on my belly
oh god it didn't help and then now this
baloney how do I win I don't even know
how to get a half way up the hill yeah
must L see like a shadow in the night it
can't hit a target he can't see too bad
I'm standing out kinda in the open here
I got a drop in the chute cuz it takes
him a while to reload he can't miss I
know that I'm on shoot me you bastard
Joe my brother ha ha ha ha ha he missed
me I go back and forward and then go do
a loop-de-loop in the rock he made me ha
ah hey Bisbee oh god whatever out there
oh gosh stop that this game game is
vicious it's vicious
the heart attack that's what this is in
a different way
not like in a scare jump scare away in a
sort of I'm dead way okay come on how do
you how do we do this
what is this oh you're mr. Joe Oh too
fast for you I'm jumping I'm jumping Wow
oh my god I he got me got me he can hit
the broadside of a barn not exactly a
small target I guess so let's roll whoa
somebody's drunk
Oh No Oh No ah I fell to the side that
time okay this game is really really
really hot and I don't know how to win I
don't know how to win can I like stick
out a fake version of my head to
distract him please that would help help
a lot can I throw a rock could I throw
something but I poked my head out
without being have it blown off I like
my head I have a very pretty face I
don't I don't need you to ugly it up for
me ah ah
should I run shall I run guys do I run I
run yeah I'm in the oven look who hit
Snoopy what was that what was I doing a
just I just stood there in the open
maybe if I hide he'll forget that I'm
here and then I surprised him with a
burst of speed damn it damn it damn it
all the gyal this geeking piece of dick
I can't even begin to understand how
cabig oh my goodness ah
how do i how do i win how do i win this
it's impossible now you miss me
whoa whoa what's this crazy acrobatics
hey yo hey yeah
Sami les coming to shopping ah whoa whoa
what was that
why did I whoa whoa okay I did it I did
a trick there but I'm like ducking to
the side
it's perfect it's a perfect strategy but
I ducked my head right into the way of
the bullet and then it blew it off my
head hey ah hey y'all hey whoa whoa whoa
yah
okay that wasn't very effective at all
this game is hard that's what she said
nah
yeah oh no I was way behind it that was
bull I found my epic strategies to jump
around
ah jump lean right into the bullet come
on
this son of a [ __ ] huh yeah yeah oh
there is no way to win this it's all I
didn't even do anything that time got my
hammock alright stop bad boy why now why
all of a sudden you kill me I'm going
down to your bond yeah I'm charging
screw it I'm straight up straight on he
can't hit a target that's coming
straight at him no way no way no way no
way
ha ha ha
escaped I don't know how to beat you the
law got dive into cover la no hang on
it's hard with see there I wish it was
like space or controllers don't know
ah I didn't dive into cover hang up huh
ha no ha ha ha this isn't working as
well as it was before
No there we go no that was on the ground
I was already dead okay I don't know how
to beat this it's really hard but you
guys should give it a try because it's
really well made I will admit that it's
just that I'm not good at it so the link
is in the description below if you can
get to the top of the hill like send me
a picture on Twitter or something of you
see what the end of is because I can't
ah
I'm just doing my crazy acrobatic stunts
so I must look pretty stupid to him but
anyway so that's all I got for now so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
ah
I got bigger
one
god
Oh
that